I have a Red Alert corruption story for
you today this is the worst of
government to see I previously reported
to you that dr. Rick bright former
deputy assistant secretary for
preparedness and response for Health and
Human Services dr. Rick bright says he
was pushed out of his role and he
believes it's because he was regularly
going to the Trump administration and
saying were unprepared to deal with
coronavirus he believes it's because he
refused to go out and promote the use of
hydroxychloroquine as a coronavirus
treatment despite Donald Trump doing it
publicly and despite the Trump
administration pushing dr. Rick bright
to do it he has been working on a
whistleblower complaint which he filed
yesterday it's devastating and we'll get
to it in a moment but the corruption is
that three days before Donald Trump
fired the Inspector General of Health
and Human Services who is the inspector
general that would have been receiving
and investigating this complaint from
dr. Rick bright Christie grim she was
replaced with the total Trump loyalists
what a coincidence
Trump couldn't stop the whistleblower
complaint so he made sure that the
person handling the complaint
investigating the complaint would be
someone loyal to him rather than someone
whose loyalty is to the facts and to
reality grim was already on Trump's bad
side because she was willing to publish
a report in January saying hey we have
huge shortages of PPE we're short on
testing supplies if we're going to deal
with a pandemic we are woefully
unprepared Trump didn't like it and this
was a great opportunity to get her out
before she had the opportunity to handle
dr. Rick brights
whistleblower complaint from clear out
there will be no dissension in the ranks
Trump must be placated all the time
constantly or you will be fired so that
gets us to yesterday dr. Rick bright
files his whistleblower complaint and if
even 10% of what's in it is true it is
absolutely stunning it is everything we
feared it's everything we've been
suspecting was going on in the Trump
administration in the lead-up to the
virus in December in January and dr.
Rick Wright explains that early
coronavirus
warnings that he brought to the
administration were ignored let's check
out some of what he said yesterday
during a press conference
time after time I was pressured to
ignore her or dismiss expert and
scientific recommendations and instead
to award lucrative contracts based on
political connections in other words I
was pressured to let politics and
cronyism drive decisions over the
opinions of the best scientists we have
in government and ultimately I was
removed from my position because of my
continued insistence that the government
invests funds allocated by Congress
hard-earned taxpayer dollars to address
the COBIT 19:00 and invest them into
safe and scientifically vetted solutions
so this is absolutely devastating you
can listen to the 6 or 7 minutes during
which he outlines everything that he
alleges went on but I'll tell you some
of what it includes dr. Rick bright says
he went to the administration and said
were short on supplies and masks Trump
officials didn't believe him not enough
to do anything about it
he was right of course he says that as
his warnings about the virus were
confirmed the indifference that he was
experiencing turned to outright
hostility against him dr. Rick bright
says he was pressured to give lucrative
contracts to whoever the Trump
administration wanted I've told you that
there's been a lot of money made on
coronavirus and one of the ways is by
getting contracts with the government to
produce PPE or other things sweetheart
deals as we might call them Rick Wright
says he's blowing the whistle he says
they came to me they told me give the
deals to these particular companies and
of course we already knew dr. Rick
bright says he was pressured to promote
hydroxychloroquine as a treatment for
coronavirus he pushed back he said it's
not scientifically sound we should
really limit it to these trials much
like a dozen other medications that were
testing the Trump administration wanted
chloroquine promoted far and wide he
refused to do it and he was transferred
out of that role now the legal argument
is going to be more complicated for dr.
Rick brights lawyers his lawyers say
when he was warning the administration
about the lack of PPE and the lack of
coronavirus a danger more broadly that
his actions were protected by the
whistleblower protection act that is a
questionable case to make oh it's gonna
be difficult
I mean intuitively certainly
colloquially it's accurate but the
counterpoint would be he may have been
ignored when he was blowing that when he
was raising alarm but it didn't violate
the whistleblower protection act
you could argue also that he wasn't
fully ignored but it's going to be a
difficult case to prove so we have two
issues here really we have dr. Rick
bright being pushed out after being
ignored that's tragic it's horrifying it
builds on what we've suspected for some
time that the Trump administration did
get early warnings about the virus but
ignored them at this point but we know
that that took place in dr. Rick bright
was just one piece of that the second
piece is Trump fired the person who
would be investigating ric reitz
assertions what use to us our inspectors
general if the president will just fire
the ones that actually investigate
things Trump doesn't want investigated
now we can deal with that there's a bill
that's meant to protect inspectors
general to Democrats wrote it Senator
Chris Murphy and Senator Jim Cooper and
under this bill the inspectors general
can't just be removed from office for
political reasons they could only be
removed for quote permanent incapacity
inefficiency neglect of duty malfeasance
or conviction of a felony or convict on
duct involving moral turpitude that is a
much higher standard than Trump wants to
stop their investigation so he fires
them so we have a bill that's been
written which would deal with this good
luck passing it in a Republican Senate
which reminds us of the importance of
helping Democrats take control of the
Senate in November now of course Fox
News
oay n whoever Hannity Rush Limbaugh
they're going to say about a bill like
that look at these Democrats trying to
prevent bad people from being removed of
course that's not what they're trying to
do so this is all catastrophic
at every level and sadly when we get to
the question of consequences it's up to
us I mean listen a what who's going to
do anything to Trump here all we can do
is remove him in November we've got to
vote this garbage of an administration
out in November because Trump's fired
numerous inspectors general there have
been no consequences
Trump has manipulated the people in
charge of even potentially overseeing
the actions or inactions of the federal
government doesn't make a difference
really I mean it has not there have been
no consequences okay you know a couple
people went to prison or going to prison
for short short sentences but the big
malfeasance of the constant corrupt
crony capitalism and distortions of
reality from this administration while
covering up their misdeeds by firing
people and lying and doing all sorts of
other things there's really been no
consequence to that it's up to us it's
up to us to remove this garbage in
November I hope that we will let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman make sure you're following me
there and make sure you are signed up to
the all new David Pakman show newsletter
by signing up at david pakman.com